speaking of things that uh the legacy
world calls bitcoin a scam a ponzi
scheme nonsense we saw john paulson
famous for uh the housing short trade
recently say it was all going to zeros a
bubble etc one of the things that young
people are starting to wake up to is the
idea of social security now social
security was originally created with the
idea that you would pay in dollars into
this program they would be able to
invest those dollars and they would use
the interest off the yield the return on
those investments to pay out later in
your life for retirement what they would
end up doing is they would build up this
massive war chest of people contributing
to the social security program they
would be able to generate all of this
money and then they would be able to pay
it out and they would basically be half
the government able to provide social
security payments to those that are
oldest in our society
whatever you think about the political
system and the government paying people
etc
that's a pretty rational thought we're
going to put money in here we're going
to invest it we're going to use the
yield we're going to pay people out
later okay the problem ended up being
that people have lived much longer than
we originally thought and in many cases
we've had to pay people more than we
originally thought but it gets scarier
than that the social security board of
trust announced in a press release
yesterday that the old age and survivors
insurance
will be depleted by 2033.
we'll be out of money gone done see ya
2033 the old age of survivors insurance
so there's basically two different types
of social security trust funds the first
is the old age and survivors insurance
oasi
and they are claiming that that is now
going to be depleted by 2033 which is
one year earlier than they were saying
last year so already in a 12-month
period they went from saying it's going
to be done by 2034. now they're saying
oh wait it's going to be done in 2033.
so oasi the second is a disability
insurance trust fund which will be
depleted by 2057.
catch
2057 is eight years earlier than they
were saying last year so the situation
is not only bad in that these funds are
actually going to be depleted meaning
that there is no capital left but even
more so is that every year they appear
to be moving up the end of life of the
fund sooner and sooner and sooner to the
point where many of the people who are
paying in today will not have any money
in these funds at a later date now
it might be unpopular but
if i was an investor and i went out to
raise capital and i said to investors
hey give me money and when you give me
your money i'm gonna go invested in the
market and in the future i'm going to
pay you the profits from this fund and
you sitting at home gave me let's say a
hundred dollars and i went and i
invested that hundred dollars and then
when you came to me and said hey i would
like ten dollars back i said to you no
problem and i paid you the ten dollars
but the difference is that i didn't
actually pay you out of the hundred
dollars that you gave me your principal
nor did i pay you ten dollars of profit
off of your hundred dollars instead what
i did was i simply went to john and i
said hey john i need ten dollars and
john invested ten dollars in the fund
and then i took john's ten dollars to
pay you back that is a ponzi scheme
that's exactly how a ponzi scheme works
is you raise money from new investors to
pay old investors a ponzi scheme now
social security again i do not think
that there was ever an intention to do
anything nefarious malicious or negative
with this program but what we have come
to now is that the payments that are due
to people do not come from the return on
invested capital we are now dipping into
the new contributions of people to pay
out the older people it is a ponzi
scheme that is by definition it's a
ponzi scheme and so again you can argue
that it's for the greater good that we
should keep the program you could argue
all this stuff but what you have to
understand is that if you are paying
into social security and you are
depending on that for your retirement
later in life that is probably not going
to be a very good idea so when you look
at the social security program what you
need to understand is that it is your
duty it is required of you by law to pay
into the program you cannot not pay into
the program you have to pay into the
program which has all sort of moral or
ethical questions around whether the
government should make you pay into this
or not but that is what the rules are
today you have to do it
do not rely on social security being
there if you're a young person when you
go to retire instead what you must think
about is how do you personally build
your own private retirement you cannot
rely on the public retirement system and
so you are going to have to create your
own retirement fund whether it's through
an ira whether it's through some sort of
401k et cetera you have to be smart
about this because these funds will not
be here they're telling you that the old
age
uh old age and survivors insurance will
be gone by 2033. 2033 we're talking
about 12 years gone the disability
insurance trust fund will be gone by
2057. done and the people who are paying
into it now are helping to pay this
stuff so it ends up being a massive
massive difference between what we were
promised and what we are getting doesn't
mean that it's going to change but it
appears that this is not going well
right john
yeah i hate social security
i'll just say it
it's a ponzi scheme and i want to bring
up the definition of a ponzi scheme so
everyone listening can actually
understand what we're talking about a
form of fraud in which belief in the
success of a non-existent enterprise is
fostered by the payment of quick returns
to the first investors from money
invested by later investors
that's the definition of what's going on
yeah
and again look all we're saying is this
isn't gonna stop we understand that the
government is different than a private
citizen or an investment firm etc but
let's just call it what it is and then
move on with and understand that you're
not gonna change it at home you have to
take care of you no one is coming to
save you the government's not coming to
save you no one's going to give you
retirement money et cetera you got to
build your own retirement savings so
that you are prepared when you want to
stop working without relying on this
social security program
i wish you we just didn't have to pay it
i hate that so so the easiest way to
look at it though is that the benefits
for retirees are being paid by current
workers right in the most
over-generalized concept
but to make that work you either have to
have more kids every single year right
so the population has to keep increasing
with the amount of kids that everyone is
having and retirees have to be dying at
a consistent rate essentially right or
at a an age that is earlier than
expected
right now the life expectancy has
dramatically increased over the last 50
years or so and where and the uh the
birth rate has been going down the last
few years so if you're looking in that
context like it's set up for failure
from the beginning and we're seeing that
now with whatever year they said that
the funds were eventually going to run
out that we're running into the issue of
not being able to pay out these claims
preach joe preach
the uh we have two quotes here that
we're going to pull up the first is from
uh kilo kilolo
kajazaki i'm going to mess it up sorry
uh i apologize the acting commissioner
of the social security program who i'm
assuming is a very good person is doing
the best they can given the situation
that they're in uh but the quote says
the pandemic and its economic impact
have had an effect on social security's
trust funds and the future course of the
pandemic is still uncertain yet social
security will continue to play a
critical role in the lives of 65 million
beneficiaries and 176 million workers
and their families during 2021. now one
thing that is clear and i saw somebody
in the comments talking about this is uh
i do not believe that you pay social
security if you are not receiving income
right it's as a portion of your income
so if you don't work then you don't
contribute and if we look at last year
we had you know for a couple of weeks
six million people at a time filing for
first time unemployment claims over tens
of millions of americans lost their jobs
that means that capital that was
supposed to be contributed into the
social security program did not get
contributed last year and therefore it
makes sense as to why they begin to
shorten that end of life why they have
to bring it forward but that doesn't
change the fact that the people who are
paying into it are
necessary it is absolutely necessary for
more people to pay in in order to
continue to fund the beneficiaries and
the fact that they have 65 million
beneficiaries means that we cannot just
shut it off go away etc there would be a
massive negative impact so it's a very
very complex situation it's a very bad
situation but you at home you have to
contribute if you're receiving income
but please please please do not rely on
this then we have a quote from janet
yellen she said quote having strong
social security and medicare programs is
essential in order to ensure secure
retirement for all americans especially
for our most vulnerable populations the
biden-harris administration is committed
to safeguarding these programs and
ensuring they continue to deliver
economic security and health care to
older americans and quote so that leads
me to a little bit of data real quick if
we look at both funds uh for the social
security program hold approximately 2.9
trillion dollars in them that's an 11
billion dollar increase from 2019. so
it's growing a little bit but in 2020
social security paid out
1.09 so about 1.1 trillion in benefits
to 65 million beneficiaries so we only
have 2.9 trillion in the funds and we
paid out 1.1 trillion to the
beneficiaries in 2020. the trust took in
1.1
trillion last year about 1 trillion from
payroll tax contributions 41 billion
from taxable benefits and 76 billion
dollars in interest now again the reason
why this is interesting if you break
down the numbers is that in 2020 social
security paid out 1.1 trillion in
benefits but they only had as income 76
billion in interest it's completely
upside down given what the model
originally was supposed to be the
original model was i put money into
social security you generate a return
you then pay the return to older folks
and that ends up being able to support
retirement we could we can't do it we're
paying out a trillion dollars in
benefits but we're only receiving 76
billion dollars a year in interest on
top of that if you were to add in the
taxable benefits 76 plus 41 i'm not a
mathematician but i believe that that is
117 and if that is correct then 117
billion dollars ends up being much less
than the 1.1 trillion that they have to
pay out so the only way to continue to
pay social security benefits in america
is that we need the
one trillion dollars in payroll tax
contributions to continue if at any
point we stop funding social security
from the existing
people who are working the whole program
is done bankrupt bk see ya it's over and
that is the problem is that this is no
longer about a secure sustainable thing
if i was to evaluate this from an
investment standpoint and i saw these
numbers i would not invest it is a bad
use of money it's too risky at any point
this could flip and be underwater and so
therefore because it is a government
program because it is not a economic
actor we are trying to help the 65
million beneficiaries it has a different
goal it is not trying to drive a return
for the government is not trying to
drive a return for the individual
investors that are contributing to it
but we still must call it out operating
cost in 2020 was 6.3 billion dollars
think about that for a second 6.3
billion dollars to operate social
security program and the social security
estimates the number of americans 65 or
older will increase to more than 79
million by 2035. so currently we have 54
million americans that are 65 or older
and they estimate that 79 million will
be 65 or older by 2035 a continued
extension of life expectancy continued
better healthcare etc so my question to
joe and john is if we can't end the
program does that mean that the only way
for this to continue to survive is
either one tax people more from a social
security standpoint or two the
government strokes a big boy check to
social security programs and basically
shores it up to make it last longer yeah
one or the two you can increase taxes or
you can just pay for it right print more
money whatever it is but i think they'll
probably actually uh start reducing the
amount right so i think you were talking
about it earlier they could go to 70
cents on the dollar 60 cents on the
dollar write some reduced amount of what
you're expected to get
um but we'll see i think they're going
to intervene in some kind of capacity
right when people are expecting this i
the wild said i read earlier was like
nine out of 10 people rely on social
security income when they retire so only
one out of every 10 people uh can
operate their kind of normal life
without it in some capacity right maybe
it's you depend on it for a few things
maybe everything
but nine out of 10 people are reliant on
social security income so that's we're
really not that far away it's 15 years
away uh of when we're gonna be expected
to start reducing these payments the
government's gonna have to do something
whether it's increasing the amount of uh
of government assistance that they're
providing taxing the rich doing whatever
but we're too far into it now where if
you tell people hey look you're relying
on this income in 15 years in just over
a decade you're planning on retiring and
you're going to need this income to live
off of they're going to have to do
something i found it very interesting
ken langone who people may or may not
know is a co-founder of home depot very
well-known wall street financier um and
he was on cnbc recently and elizabeth
warren was on and they basically had
them have a conversation uh remotely and
ken langowin right after elizabeth
warren and he says it's absolutely
absurd he's a billionaire and he's
receiving like four or five thousand
dollar social security checks every
month he and he basically was saying i
don't need four or five thousand dollars
a month but you guys are paying me a
billionaire social security why is that
happening and i think at his point
although he didn't explicitly say it i
think his point basically was there's
got to be a cutoff why are we paying
rich people social security what are the
cost savings how much longer can we
extend the program if we were to say hey
if you have over 10 million dollars in
assets you don't get social security
over 5 million in assets you don't get
social security what what is the cutoff
i don't know what it is somebody should
figure out what that number makes sense
but my guess is that you could
drastically reduce the cost of
administering the program you could
drastically reduce the amount of capital
that you're paying out rather than 1.1
trillion could you get it down to a
trillion could you get it down to 900
billion i don't know but there's some
big number that you probably could put a
dent in there and then second or i'm
sorry third is you also could extend the
life cycle of these funds so it's
getting smarter about how we administer
the programs but i think that ken had a
great um you know point when he's saying
look i'm a billionaire i'm getting
social security how is that possible hey
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
software.compomp and make sure you come
back and watch more of the best business
show we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help